let's get a little practice doing the
khan academy exercise marking data on
line plots so right over here it says
tessa measure the distance from her
house to several locations to the
nearest half kilometer
all right and so they have different
locations and it tells her that it tells
us the distance from her house to each
of these locations so from her house to
the school is three and a half
kilometers to the library's five and a
half kilometers to the park is two
kilometers the movie theater four
kilometers to the post office five and a
half kilometers and then they ask us how
many dots should be on a line plot of
these measurements
so a line plot and they have one down
here a line plot this is literally a
number line and what we do is we put as
many dots there are at a certain at a
certain point in the line so if we have
two data points at five and a half we
would put two dots right over there but
we'll get to that in a second but
whenever they're just asking us how many
dots should be on a line plot of these
measurements well we should make a dot
for each of these data points and there
are one two three four five data points
here so there's five data points that
i'm going to want to put on my line plot
then they say click a create a line plot
that shows all of the measurements click
above the marking on the number line
that matches each measurement click
higher to add more dots above the same
marking click lower to add fewer dots
so they say that the distance from the
school to tesla's house is three and a
half kilometers so we would want to put
a dot at three and a half and i do that
just by clicking
clicking right over there three and a
half so that's one data point at three
and a half halfway between three and
four
let's do it for the next ones five and a
half that's the distance from the
library to our house
five and a half
then we have
two kilometers
two kilometers distance from
two kilometers was the distance from the
park to our house then the movie theater
is four kilometers i wish you could see
it all on one screen
four kilometers
and then
the post office is also five and a half
kilometers so you actually have two data
points at five and a half kilometers so
right here i've just constructed a line
plot at different points on the number
line i'm showing how many data points we
have so we have one data point at two
kilometers one at three and a half
kilometers one at four kilometers and
two at five and a half kilometers and
notice we said five data we said we
would have five dots and we have one two
three four five one for each data point
let's do this one more time let's check
make sure we got it right now let's do
one more all right
measure the length
measure the length of each line to the
nearest quarter inch to the collect data
for the line plot below
to make your measurements drag the ruler
on top of the lines align the left end
of the ruler with the left end of the
lines then read of the le the length of
each line from the right end of the line
all right so really i just want to
measure i just want to measure oh this
is i didn't need to tilt it like that
i just want to measure each of these
lines
so this green line right over here looks
like it is
six and this is split into one two three
four and it looks like it's six and
three
fourths
six and three fourths the green line is
six and three-fourths inches long
so we have one data point at six and
three-fourths
so i'll put that right over there
then we have the red line
is let's see this is seven
and two fourths or seven and a half it's
halfway between seven and eight so seven
and two fourths are seven and a half
so
halfway between seven and eight is right
over there and then
finally i have the purple line
the purple line let's see
that is eight and three fourths inches
long notice i aligned it right at the
beginning right over there and it goes
all the way to eight and one two three
out of the four
eight and three-fourths inches long
so let me eight and three-fourths so
there you go i have one line that was
six and three-fourths one line that was
seven and two fourths or seven and a
half and then one line that's eight and
three fourths inches long
let's check our answer
let's do one more this is actually a lot
of fun
all right we gotta measure things again
so let's see
the green line
green line is exactly three inches long
three inches long so let's plot it right
over there
and then we have the red line is exactly
let's see three and three fourths inches
long
three and three fourths let's put a dot
right over there
and then
the purple line
is three inches long as well so i have
another data point
at three inches of two in so two of the
lines were three inches and one of them
is three and three-fourths
and we are
and
we're done